[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
very excited to be talking about all
things trauma all things development all
things authenticity we have Francesca
Maximo joining us hello hello nice to
see you Ellen such a pleasure yeah it's
great
really appreciate your work a lot really
grateful that Ron made the connection
happen and made it all come together
this is this is really important
conversation for those that don't know
Francesca's background she is a
certified mindfulness meditation teacher
she's also trauma-informed and she is
also poet and author a journalist she is
the host of the wise girl video podcast
which is awesome you can check that out
in the link below and just after looking
at your work and understanding more
about your passion for helping people I
have fallen deeply in love with what you
do so I'm very excited to yeah so let's
start off with kind of a big history
perspective on civilizations kind of
what we love doing to just a little bit
civilization so here so here we are
we're stewards of Earth after a long
period of evolution and we're figuring
out how to work together with
exponential technology with a big
population boom it's like a little bit
of like a roll of the dice it's kind of
like where you're born in the world and
then that's the you know that's the
stimuli you take in that can be trauma
that can be radical wealth it can be
radical poverty so tell us about kind of
your current synthesis on all of that I
mean I think what you say is you know
subject what a lot of people have
different ideas about how do we come
into the world why do we come into the
world when we come into the world and
all of that
my personal take on it is is pretty much
rooted in ancient wisdom
you know traditions and insights that
that I think have been borne out over
time in my own direct experience that
have sort of been you know talked about
by others also from their own direct
experience is that we're all subject to
causes and conditions so there's gonna
be stuff that's influenced how you came
into this world how you get imprinted
when you are brought into this world and
then how you move forward as you are
adulting in this world and that there
are factors there that are more in our
control than others at different points
in time and that a lot of times people
think about especially here in Western
philosophy sort of this meritocracy or
pull yourself up by your bootstraps or
if you work hard you'll be able to
achieve what it is that you want and
need and for some people that very much
is true
other people don't start with the same
kinds of opportunities and so it
wouldn't be true and then there's the
piece about well even if you have sort
of opportunities that you see on paper
if you don't have awareness you don't
have choice and so what we find is that
a lot of folks who actually appear to
have a lot of choice and seem to be
theoretically living lives that are sort
of really free or open or interconnected
or filled with possibility don't really
have full awareness of how they're
constituted know biologically
physiologically evolutionarily neuro
scientifically and all the ways in which
they're imprinting and their awareness
and the narratives and the story stories
that they've come to believe about
themselves influence how it is that they
go about comporting themselves day after
day and it can kind of narrow the vision
kind of narrow the field of what you
even see and so the whole point of being
more we're opening ourselves up to
curiosity what don't I know what else is
possible here what else could be going
on who-who else is influencing me or has
or whatever from any realm if you're
talking about civilization and universes
or constellations and whatever can I be
curious about that and then see what
wants to emerge or have I already named
something come up with a preconceived
notion on what it is and hence limited
my options from the very beginning and I
think a lot of people do that we've you
know talked about sheeple we've talked
about sort of moving along with the pack
and there's certainly a little bit of
pragmatism not saying we all should just
live in this world of non-duality we're
all just one and the cosmos er I mean
that's true at a certain level and it's
also true that we live in these bodies
and we walk around and here in San
Francisco there's homeless folks on the
street that are struggling and you know
there's you and me sitting here having a
nice cup of coffee and a conversation
and there's a lot of reasons why we're
here and they're there and what do we
want to do about that yeah you hinted at
these really crucial points one of them
is this opportunity so throughout
throughout history we've seen that the
more that we present people with an
opportunity for them to pursue what they
find most meaningful or fulfilling in
their lives the more that person kind of
realizes their fullest potential in the
world so kind of making a baseline of
these basic needs being met across the
planet for humans is super crucial this
other thing you pointed out is awareness
so the awareness that one has to develop
through their life and also have a
social fabric that helps them understand
that they can be what they want as that
meaning most meaningful person the most
meaningful goal most fulfilling person
that they can strive to become is is
that you know this communal awareness
that we have to have I like I like those
two a lot so this is this is you know
you point out like the instance that we
have here where a lot of what happens
in terms of like resource distributions
and we can kind of see like the Pareto
principle apply to like almost
everything and what we see is we see a
very large concentration of wealth in
the hands of a very small amount of
people and tremendous non wealth
accumulation in a vast majority of
people and that's kind of just like the
monopoly effect of how things Pareto
principle out and it's not really
exactly clear on how to help with the
realigning of our values and structures
to redistribute slash and power slash
figure out what to do there while
simultaneously like we were articulating
earlier figuring out this how to
eradicate the things like traumas that
can sometimes birth people into a
circumstance where they can't actually
fulfill their fullest potential so how
can we address that again I mean I you
know most of the stuff that I'm sharing
is not necessarily new but I'll share it
because I think it's valuable and that
is that you know greed I mean scale
maximization how wise is that meaning
that you know there's a lot of things
that we do that we don't even question
right because we're operating out of a
framework where maximization of profit
or scale or taking things I mean we hear
about this all the time and that's good
for the bottom line and that's a
framework one can look at that as a
framework but it's kind of rooted in
more for me is less for you because
there's only so many resources and you
know and if we look at what's behind the
need I mean you know if you look at the
work of dr. Marshall Rosenberg or even
like AB or Maite who's the addiction
specialist that you know I know that you
admire that his work as do i mm-hmm
what's the need what's behind the need
why do we always want more you know why
are we so insatiable we're either none
of that
have any of that or I want more give me
more
you know Britney Spears song why does it
have to be that way
can we get curious about what it is that
we're always wanting more up so my point
about this is just that it's it's if we
can be sort of those who are in white
skin privileged positions those who are
in socio-economic positions those are in
able-bodied positions those who are
given a certain amount of privilege
either intellectually academically
having a platform whether it's the
opportunity to share something like this
to recognize that that is in fact a
platform and an opportunity and to then
get curious about not only one's own
limitations or traumas or whatever it is
and sort of bring a friendly attention
to that as opposed to I wish I weren't
this way I can't stand this I never want
to look at this again I hate my family I
haven't talked to them in 20 years I'm
better off without them I haven't talked
to you know my ex or whatever it is yes
all of that may be true I'm not saying
we have to revisit everything in order
to drag it through the mud but the more
that we understand our Constitution our
neurophysiology and our biology then we
can bring that into awareness then we
can be in a place of choice then we can
be in less of a place of reactivity then
we can hold our seat and we can learn
how to respond more wisely to the
challenges in the world including
economic inequality or including poverty
an act from a place of wisdom and not
just from intellect wisdom is embodied
wisdom is collective it's not just
individual and we don't open up I don't
think any more to this collective wisdom
that very much is here that we forget
about because we have been sort of
programmed with the idea that we have to
do it all alone
and that's counterintuitive to the way
that mammals just are and we are of
course Homo sapiens sapiens the ones who
are aware that we're aware when we
actually are able to get out of our you
know lower brain structures in our
limbic brain and move forward up into
our prefrontal cortex right but we can't
just always have executive functioning
with our left grain we got to be willing
to kind of dip into what the
and our embodiment has to teach us and
that is something that the more we get
comfortable with how to do that because
we're not trained to do that that's not
a skill set that we grow up with we
learn ABCs and we learn multiplication
tables but we don't learn relational
skills and we don't learn skills about
relating to ourselves yeah that's a
major skill set that is looking like
we're gonna be integrating back into
childhood development it seems like it
was lost over the last couple hundred
years and now it's being reintegrated
this heart centric thinking this unity
thinking the social emotional
intelligence empathy eye contact
immersing oneself in the perspective of
another all that and this is a
collective learning you talked about as
well as that there's these hundred
billion people that lived and died
before us to build civilization that
we're not even grateful for so many of
the things that they made ubiquitous to
make our lives so easy so then it's the
wisdom that's embodied in us through
this transgenerational building of
civilization that we have to realize
that we can't just syringe off the top
all of this financial success just
syringe it away from thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of humans just so
that we can purchase a fifth car or a
fifth house or a fifth boat or whatever
that these materialistic rings and
necklaces and and that they don't mean
anything compared to the life of another
human that is starving or that is that
has creative potential that is not being
unleashed into the well the thing is as
long as we see someone is separate from
us we'll always feel as though well it's
okay if I have this or they don't or but
if we see us as a larger family then it
changes the whole terms of the debate I
mean the age-old question is cui bono
who benefits but if we see as though we
have skin in the game I mean we have the
Super Bowl coming up right we have skin
in the game this is our collective we
think we live in a bubble because we
have certain privileges so we have
theoretically more choice but not really
we're all sort of in the soup together
and so the more that we kind of have a
collect
lenz so usually people of color are
people who are marginalized see things
from more of a collective lens people
who come from positions of privilege the
lens through which they're looking at
things tends to be more individual and
that in and of itself sets up a
framework that then comes up with a
certain way of thinking or kind of
thinking so when you broaden the lens
which is sort of the work of fine
fulness which is sort of why you know
these trauma you know sort of somatic
therapies and and approaches and
integration can be so helpful is you're
dropping in to the totality of your own
experience physically right here now in
the present moment we're recognizing the
relational field for example here
between you and me
Ron's here he's off camera but he's over
there he's with us also in the room all
of our ancestors are in the room all of
yours from mountain era all of mine from
Italy and from Haiti and from Africa
before that and Spain and the Dominican
Republic before that and are these not
partially all within us embodied and to
what extent have we even been in touch
with any of that to what extent do we
just wake up in the morning brush our
teeth go to the bathroom figure out what
we're gonna have for breakfast and then
go about our day and that's why it's
sati is is it means cultivation
mindfulness is the remembering
remembering meaning if I'm dismembered
I'm fragmented trauma is the re you know
trauma healing is the re integration
mindfulness is the re integration to
become from hol hol a separate to
integrate it back together and when we
start to do that work with ourselves and
we have the courage to do that and we
find ways to do that that are safe that
are titrated that aren't just like
falling off the water fall into this you
know whatever then we start to actually
feel like wow I'm in my body
I can be here I can move about in the
world I'm not just like sort of trying
to hide from the world or have these
preconceived notions I can stay more
open and curious about what else is out
there what else is possible everybody
loves a good brainstorming session right
you're hinting at this and we're we're
told we're going to transition it
because this is perfect timing for it
this notion of dosing or of titrating
one's expansion of awareness to being
more radically whole themselves through
the transgenerational wisdoms and being
able to tap more into that and
understanding the the collective more
unity thinking that it we don't just
push a child into a swimming pool that's
six feet deep and go good luck you know
you you take a child and you hold them
while they practice swimming and and
that's the notion of developmental
psychology you develop one's faculties
of awareness and so when when it comes
to things like better understanding
one's radical wholeness as well as the
transgenerational where we're going I'm
I'm okay let's let's let's explore this
what's really putting that one down but
now I doubt that would down they're all
in the menu I just want to say that my
father threw me into Lake Winnipesaukee
teach me how to swim back a long time
and Ron you're still here you survived
your organism made it yeah Lake
Winnipesaukee and all so so there may be
potentially even different ways for
teaching styles for maybe there is some
where you dose a lot in some way right
away you dose some very very little one
of the examples is when you have a
tremendous amount of fear or anxiety
towards something like public speaking
right now there's a lot of kids Douglas
rushkoff is just on the show he's been
ten five years and he's like more and
more people are kids are coming to my
class was like I here's my excuse I
can't publicly speak here's my excuse I
can't do group work but I'm here to
learn it stuff well okay well you got to
build up your immune system a little bit
so what is it about the thing that
you're most fearful of of public
speaking or are they doing group work
and how can we maybe if you can't look
at someone's eyes maybe we can start by
just looking for a little
and then maybe we looked and then ask a
question and then we maybe well that's
even behavioral I would go back further
I would say what is the need what is it
needing how is this serving you why is
it helpful why is this thought or B
first of all it's a thought I can't do
public speaking it's not actually true I
mean it may be what you think or maybe
what you're believing but it's a thought
so number one that's a thought you know
just like they say feelings are real and
emotion they're real but feelings aren't
facts in the sense that they're very
real to you and they are real but
they're not like the only reality right
and so it's a time when I'm dealing with
a breakup and my heart is broken of
course I'm feeling so devastated of
course when I'm about to have to go
onstage to do a presentation and I can't
brave I'm having a panic attack or
something like that and I'm freaked out
of course that's like real that's an
embodied in somatic thing okay so before
that happens before we start working on
behavioral stuff or anything like that
what are you believing how did that come
to be
what do you noticing when you sit there
and you think about I need to do group
work or Appellate usually and I say this
very generally it goes back to some kind
of shame some kind of embarrassment what
that means is you're gonna be ousted
from the tribe that means you're not
going to get food that means you're not
gonna survive that means you're gonna
die okay
so if I do this it's to stay safe so if
you look at dr. Stephen port is probably
bagel theory all this stuff you'll
mostly people do stuff that they think
is going to help them stay safe but a
lot of people walk around thinking that
the Rope is a snake even still now and
they don't know how to reset the nervous
system to a place where they see it for
what it really is which is the whole
point is clarity right you want to say
oh my god it's a snake I don't want to
step on that you don't want to go step
on everything you don't get by the Koba
but that's wisdom that's discernment
that's very different from just having
some blanket thing up I need to stay
safe so I'm not going to
I'm not gonna try to have a relationship
because my heart's been broken
let's get curious about what's
underneath it how did you first learn I
mean if you go to attachment theory with
John Bowlby and Mary Ainsworth there's a
ton of people out there now that are
talking about this
do you have secure attachment which is
you know absence see means I know you're
gonna be there even when I leave and
come back and I'm gonna be able to sort
of still check in with you and you're
gonna accept me and we're gonna hang out
together or did you have someone who was
there but they weren't really there they
weren't connected from that heart space
and what are the learnings that you had
internally about that a lot of people
who Auto regulate a lot of people who
are very what they would call dismissive
or avoidant attachment didn't have that
kind of engagement from their early
caregivers if you have people who had
unpredictable caregivers they kind of
come in they give you some love then
they sort of say well if you don't do it
this way we don't like you so much so
what do you learn you learn to always go
all-in and you're trying to anticipate
everything you're trying to prevent
something bad from happening right and
so you learned that it's all on you that
you have to fix everything that the
other person can't come in and actually
take their part and do their part so
group work would also be very
intimidating to someone because they
wouldn't feel so then they might go back
to just staying safe but their little
silo and saying I can't do this right
and then there's sometimes a combination
called disorganized attachment so the
point is is all of this trauma
resolution mindfulness and I don't mean
mindfulness when you're checking out
you're doing what they call John
Melville just passed away like spiritual
bypassing we were just sort of this
stoic you know like wooden thing it's
all about learning how to relate to life
and all of its vigor ease coming from a
place of keeping your seat and that is
where these kids could then say all
right I'm willing to engage in this
because I'm recognizing that this is a
thought and I could practice what it
would mean and what am I really
believing about what's at stake if I
were to go here and make a boo-boo
I do this with my clients all the time
there was a client who had a 5th grade
thing where she had a little project go
a little sideways and she was like
threatened by one of the little
classmates when actually not 5th grade
five years old and she was carrying this
into her twenty-something you know
year-old life on Wall Street and we did
this sort of exercise and it goes away
you have this quote that you write and
then that others I believe have said as
well just about trauma being inevitable
but it affecting us for our entire life
is totally a choice that we have the
choice to be able to reprogram our
habits and our thought patterns or the
awareness you have the awareness and if
you have the teachers around you that
can help you will hold you up in the
pool while you figure out how to swim
and all of us need some sort of like
holding up because we're such imperfect
beings but we're also simultaneously
perfect I want to be I want to I want to
touch this is super important it is the
development of the child into the world
so the research is now starting to
become more clear and I'm sure that
civilizational wisdom about this wasn't
clear in the past and then we kind of
got lost in a common thread is this
wisdom that's been lost at times but
there's a two-month period from when the
child is born is like the maternal
infant relationship that's so precious
and so delicate the child being born out
of the womb and into the mother's hands
and and the father as well then being
there to help for the first two months
of development just have the most
nurturing loving unconditional love
relationship because any sort of lack in
strong childhood development in those
first two months is has a significant
effect in their neuronal and synaptic
sculpting which causes a tremendous
long-term ailments yeah Bruce Perry
talked about that and when I interviewed
him
a few weeks ago and and anybody wants to
watch that it's a good interview
actually grace he's great but he talks
about you know two months four months
but early early and his basic point is
that through again he's a child
psychiatrist neuroscientist researcher
works with all kinds of children who've
been traumatized but that in his model
is called the neuro sequential model
talking about dosing but his his point
is that kids that have secure attachment
early on meaning unconditional love
their needs are met whatever it is that
they're you know meeting or wanting in
terms of you know Maslow's hierarchy of
needs like food clothing and shelter but
also that relational peace of being
molded into with the mothers you know or
the father's chest or the grandparents
chest or whomever it is that kids who
have that early on do better in life
even if their life circumstances shift
meaning that they enter into poverty or
they have you know hardship in some
other kind of way than kids who don't
have that are born into wealth and have
you know a roof over their head gilded
literally a silver spoon but don't have
that relational peace and don't have
that kind of attention and then they end
up with the things like I was saying
before like potentially you know
avoidant attachment or an overemphasis
on autoregulation and then that can turn
into a real dismissive quality later in
life like I didn't need anyone nobody
was there for me I'm not going to you
know give to anyone else and so you
could be rich but you could not have you
can have a poverty of an ability and
then that is again to cite Perry's
research and his next book was on
empathy that can be part of the seed of
what takes away our ability to have
empathy which is the foundation of a
compassion which is not only to feel
with empathy is that I actually can
literally like feel what you're feeling
nobody wants to get stuck there you get
burnt out mm-hmm compassion is holding
your seat with the capacity to feel with
having the wisdom and discernment to
figure out what's wise to do or not do
as we go either on a case by
or in a more global level mm-hmm oh my
goodness I just I want this I want this
to be better understood there's seven
point seven billion people now and they
all were birthed into different life
circumstances and that it's so much of
our ability to get behind the eyes of
what it is like to be born to complete
basic needs met versus complete basic
needs and not met is a huge change in
our life trajectory and so when we can
get behind the eyes we can understand
that this is where humanity lies it's
being able to make these humane loving
compassionate and pathetic connections
between other humans okay now let's go
you know that's you know this roll of
the dice you're born and you do some
bass sometimes basic needs are met
sometimes they're not and sometimes you
get the love sometimes you don't now you
get to deal with a myriad of these
circumstances in your work and how do
you best because obviously everyone has
their own mental lattice that's
developed but also you have to kind of
like you do this process of kind of like
poking and prodding I don't know - like
will you how else do you learn about
them you have to like a question I ask
them to sense into their own body and
then you learn from them sensing into
their own body so teach us about this
style of we obviously do something
similar here where we like ask people
about what they care about why it's very
important it's not on the floor okay
yeah get that grounding I just noticed
not checking out we're not going
anywhere just notice what it's like to
actually feel your feet right now on the
floor heels
balls your feet just feel that contact
and feel the support
just notice how your body sort of seated
in the chair and what it's like to feel
the contact of the skin and the back of
your thighs and your jeans on the chair
and just be aware of that that there's
support there also
and then your lower back and your
mid-back your buttocks
yeah a nice swallow and you're smiling
which is lovely but not necessary
again just noticing she's interesting
thinking about the gratitude one can
have for just the support of earth the
support of the chair correct there's
nothing that you need to be doing right
now nowhere to go nothing to do no one
to be not even TV host
and just notice if anything shifting
inside if there's an image sensation
any part of the body that maybe feels a
little bit more tingly or constricted
maybe has a color to it and give me not
it's just bringing a friendly attention
and little curiosity to what's here
what are you noticing more relaxed how
do you know you're more relaxed just uh
you can tell by your physiological state
I was way more in host mode and uh huh
yeah and now I'm just feels more like
the parasympathetic nervous systems
kicked in and just more relaxed and and
these soon out walk astir you know that
was a practice that very small very
small but you picked up on the peace
about it of it's possible to be
supported and the noticing is the key
often missing element that actually
right now right here I'm actually being
supported and there's actually right
here right now in my existence and in
yours kind of like more okay than not
okay mm-hmm yeah there's problems the
others issues the others whatever but in
the wire scheme of things right compared
to maybe the way things have been for us
maybe the way things are for others can
we just be noticing what actually is
here right now we're not creating
anything we're not inventing anything
and the awareness around it can begin to
sort of decalcify a little bit have it
patterns because we're we turn our
attention is what grows yeah so when we
open up to possibility of not just being
here well host mode got a do host mode
you know like right yeah and we all have
to perform right whether you're a Wall
Street banker whether you're a TV host
whether you're a journalist whatever it
is that you are in life a physician we
always have to do certain things I'm not
saying we are just open and gooey 24/7
right because that's not practical
that's not wise but we're learning how
to shift yeah so when we bring our
awareness into the fray we become more
able to
know what to do and what not to do and
when and it's not always just something
ubiquitous circumstance where we always
do it this way I love being able to turn
one's attention towards things like just
the support of the earth and the chair
another good one that I really like
turning the attention to is just a
gratitude for each inhalation we get to
be alive through these inhalations
another one is that we get to be alive
through these heartbeats that it's just
you know there was a couple moments when
I was tuning in word when I just really
was able to tune into how grateful I am
for that heartbeat that's happening
inside of my body and so when again so
there's like kind of this you know this
you get to function with the role that
you are as your character in this game
in the story that you're playing and
then at the same time you have a like a
gooey lovely Unity gratitude essence
that also comes in and kind of inter
plays and ebbs and flows together and
but we live in such a heavily
intellectual society that sometimes it
can be difficult to wrap in the gooey
lovey spirit into things well because
there's really a fear around trusting it
you know what would it mean to trust
that
I mean what would it mean to really
trust that there's something deep within
you and deep within others that is whole
that is connected what would it be to
trust that even on those stormy days the
Sun is still there but it's just
obscured by the clouds right now yeah
it's one of my favorite analogies it's
well it's an easy one sun's always
shining it's always bright but the thing
is is again realizing what it is that we
are believing or thinking and how we
came to believe or think that that sets
us up for sort of a default mode Network
they call it if you talk to Dan Siegel
and you go to the mid line and that's
why if you do narrative stuff you're
using the corpus callosum and you're
integrating you know what into what you
would call a cohesive narrative so this
is all the business of making sense out
of your life understanding not just what
happened to me but how did I get here
but Who am I really
and not just Who am I really but what is
this about and there really is no answer
it is just sort of a mystery like I mean
even wrong with saying over there
earlier like everything is so uncertain
and I'm like but what's certain is that
it's uncertain mm-hmm yeah that's right
we are certain about our uncertainty so
can we be curious and stay open to
what's here in this moment and then the
next moment yes there's there's another
aspect to this that I think is important
to address you walked us through a a an
exploration of being really connected to
the present being really connected to
gratitude and so much more right there
and you your your your dynamically
adjusting to how your the people you're
working with their states so teach us
about how you're figuring out what their
states are
how you're helping them work through
some of the potential traumas that
they've had in the past how you're
helping them integrate those teach us
about this well I think you'll anyone I
think who experiences regular life he
walk around you'll see that different
people have different compartments right
some people are you know they're just
more like this all the time right some
people are like this some people are
like this some people are like this
right and some people are like this and
if I were standing up you would see it
more physiologically with like your you
know the spine and that and then and a
lot of it goes back to like it's weird
what are you operating out of fight
flight freeze attach or submit are you
using these you know sort of sensory
motor psychotherapy language around
these early experiences that tend to
shape how we end up showing up in the
world you'll see some especially I won't
need names but there are certain men
that you know you always see them
photograph like this mm-hmm
interesting so when you start noticing
that like I love a client that you know
when we started working together about a
year ago they would come into the office
and they were just always you know like
kind of like this mm-hmm
you know like they're kind of like this
we did a ton of boundary work what would
it mean if you said this what would it
mean if you approached me this way what
if what would it mean I can't do that
really I can't say that really like can
we be curious about what about that
feels scary or why oh really what does
that remind you of oh really
so yes Wow if I had that experience when
I was six or seven you better believe I
wouldn't be saying extra wires II
I would have learned how to just be in
my room doing my homework also but that
carries forward when it's not looked at
so by doing these relational pieces of
what would it be like right here right
now if you said I really don't want to
go to the park with you today I don't
know if I can say that what would it
mean if you tried just right here we can
imagine it you could say in whatever
language you want it doesn't really
matter it could be like more complicated
language less complicated language and
person might just say hmmm I don't
really want to go to the park beautiful
just notice what happens in your body as
you say that I don't want to go to the
park
and then usually something will shift I
feel a little more spacious I feel a
little more whatever great just notice
that hang out there for a minute because
the body has it yet had the experience
of getting what it wants and needs so
the only experience it has is this
contracted state so it only knows how to
stay safe from what was very adaptive at
one time which is now limiting I won't
use the word maladaptive but now keeping
them from having a fuller life that they
want or being able to show up fully and
their marriages or the relationships or
being able to engage it work in a way
that they feel is respectful and getting
the kind of attention and recognition
that they need so when we practice
together
what are you believing what are you
feeling and then sending it to the body
and starting to teach the body like hey
is it okay here right now to say this to
me what would it be like to ask for what
you need it or wanted right here right
now
I mean this will show up even in sex
with women and orgasms they won't even
say what they need or want why not
what's the repercussion what's the
belief is there potential for rejection
is there potential for what would fall
apart
what's the belief around that where did
that come from
and in that case it's a lot of media
culture it's a lot of pseudo you know
sort of construction around completely
false narratives that have been
perpetuated by the porn industry not
that I have anything against erotica
because I think that's great but porn is
just another sort of system of
domination in many ways certainly not
really about consent and we've seen me
to and time's up in a variety of other
ways that you know people get their
boundaries invaded on whether it's a
woman and it's a sexual context or
whether it's a man and he can't ask for
a raise or whether it's a little kid
that wanted to have his friend over but
their parents said no because you know
they were afraid about their dirty house
or something you'd be surprised at the
way things can kind of like a pearl in
an oyster they grow from a grain of sand
but unlike a pearl they don't have the
kind of street market value but they are
just as valuable so what's your pearl
what's your core gift usually it's your
trauma usually your greatest gift to the
world as my mom would say you know your
your Achilles heel is your vein of gold
mm-hmm so what is that and the more that
we kind of start to unpack that the
better off we are yeah yeah I really
love how your your your probe reality in
ways that get us to the to the beliefs
that we have and why we've arrived at
those beliefs so what have been the
influences culturally transgenerational
II mm medically on us that have caused
us to feel certain ways and then and
then talking those things through maybe
approaching our fears because we know
that on the other side are these
treasures that we really want to get to
that help us live with that radical
authenticity that all of us strive for
maximal character development in the
story and I and I'm so happy that you
focus your life's work on
and that's this is these are these these
ways of creating these positive wakes
through you and then through other
people to their butterfly effects
exactly that's the hope the hope is is
that you know everything I I'm again I'm
sort of a conduit right like I've sort
of learned certain things and you know
done my own work and healing and I'm
still in process and as we all are but
taking this and then like when I see
clients like shift oh my god
I mean it's amazing to see their lives
open up and then how then they can show
up and then they can change and be
different because again everyone has
their gifts and works differently some
people like talking about my mom again
she's an emergency room physician she
runs a project in Africa she helps
people with a variety of things like
increasing births for you know rural
women and education on women and girls
and that's the way she is doing things
you know what I mean that's her gift my
gift is this way it's it's a little bit
more one-on-one in this way of what it
would be like to hold space right here
right now what would it be like to just
sort of say like hmm we didn't have that
then but how do you feel right here
right now with me
how is that
and a lot of it is about being regulated
yourself and we don't live in a culture
that values regulation we know when we
see it though and we know it when we
don't see it and I can see even now
you're settling more even as we wind
down we to understand the the regulatory
neurotransmission that occurs is very
interesting the sort of the sort of of
things like norepinephrine or serotonin
and dopamine and these the way that the
regulatory systems actually work from
the through the lower part of our brain
up into the cortex and how these
communicate with the rest of our body in
our environment is a very important
pillar to I think teach in in schools
and we don't quite quite get there okay
I have a there's so many other ways to
take well we're not ok let's let's talk
on there's a probably now more than ever
with exponential technology era and you
mentioned earlier you're in control or
you're being controlled in many ways by
this by this by the device might new by
the attention economy by the by the
corporate corporations that are aiming
to profiteer off of a syringe out off of
you so what what are the these ways for
us to work on you know we talked about
them a little bit this gratitude this
slowing down this empathy deal with
other humans
what are these sort of principles now
that are more important than ever for us
to teach our children and for us as
adults to embody
I think that's really a kind of a a
great question because I think that a
lot of times people feel like the minute
that they exhale like things will be out
of control right we were talking about
you know the word binary earlier we
think it's all black or all white
where's the gray you know it's all this
or all that what if we hold it what if
we held both what if we could create
enough space that there could be excuse
me in existence our own exploration into
our own beingness what if we could drop
down into that even for five minutes a
day one minute a day three minutes a day
and just notice what comes up you know
one of the biggest things about
mindfulness is that as a practice it
really is just about being able to you
know if use jon kabat-zinn this
definition which is fine you just say
you know it's being able to kind of look
at things whatever they are with the
kind friendly attention and curiosity
without you know sort of grabbing
pushing away or zoning out about it okay
fine
you started sit down and you do that a
lot of people will meditate on they want
to do their thing whatever they want to
do however they're imagining it I'm not
supposed to have any thoughts I'm just
supposed to follow my breath and out
belly breathing I have a thought about
lunch
shoot I'm a bad meditator there and then
they go into this you know thing what if
we were just noticing
I'm here now there was a thought that
happened to be about whatever the
content was once right
what if we didn't get lost in the
content but we were curious about the
process and we were able to return our
attention that's it yeah so when you
make the shift from content to process
whether it's phone whether it's
parenting whether it's work or life
trajectory career whatever you know
there's so many things that are focused
on as I was saying scalability maximum
things what are the goals what are the
outcomes what are the I don't want to
say who cares but really who cares
because the truth is when you're as you
would say in the mindfulness world when
you're on the path you will get there
you set the compass of your heart toward
a certain direction now you don't know
what kind of weather there's gonna be
but you know where you've set the
compass of your heart and then you
commit to constancy around your practice
and that practice is the process of life
it's nothing fancy it's learning to
relate to things differently it's
learning to open yourself to possibility
which might mean being happy but not
always necessarily being right right
like someone else might still have this
other idea so in terms of the next
generation is one able to do this for
oneself or does one in the five minutes
that one sits down and tries to do own
whatever right and the thought goes to
lunch what are we believing about that
what's the story I'm telling myself so
there's the me there's the whole me
that's sitting here Noble and dignified
spiritual royalty there's the activity
of the mind which secretes thoughts in
much the same way that our mouths
secrete saliva it naturally does what it
does which is have a thought can we
bring our attention
that you can do a gazillion times about
anything can you do it with road rage
when you're in the traffic on the LA
freeway can you do it when your kid is
screaming can you pause not stop but can
we go from binary of screaming kid I get
mad bad parent
mmm quiet kid you know giving them their
bottle good parent right like what about
all the stuff that's in between back to
the attachment attachment stuff its
rupture and repair we are about chaos
and synergy it's not just you know crazy
all the time because we know that
nothing is permanent
we know that nothing is personal and we
know that nothing's perfect but what it
is is it's always moving there's always
this to use Eugene Gunn's language
there's always this implicit felt since
it's moving forward life is always
moving forward in really more a spiral
than like a circle that's just back and
forth you know I feel like you're a
gerbil on a treadmill no it's a spiral
that's moving out right so how do we tap
into that when we're shutting ourselves
down
I can't think this way I have to think
this way I'm labeling it this thing even
before I've experienced it because
someone else told me that that's what it
is how do you know when's the last time
you question something when's the last
time you questioned your own way of
thinking when's the last time you
noticed a process and not content how am
I thinking about this how did I come to
believe this how did I come to walk this
way to be this way to relate this way
and then I think the more one can do
that
the more one can show up with kids I
mean yes you can do little belly
breathing there are all kinds of great
exercises greater good science center UC
Berkeley has a bunch of them Richie
Davidson's work is amazing you can do
little belly breathing with the little
teddy bears on the
on the tummies of the little kids where
they can just watch their belly rise and
fall you know you can literally have
phone time you know be turned off I know
Tristan Harris and a bunch of other
folks are doing amazing stuff in terms
of trying to like data privacy keep your
phone's off you know all that kind of
stuff that's fine I mean you can turn
your Wi-Fi off or five hours a day if
you don't want to you hit that you hit
this super well with these two words
with content versus process that's so
interesting so rather than necessarily
just looking at the thought and saying
oh lunch came up rather think about why
did lunch come up what are all the
previous behaviors of mine that have led
for me to be in that moment and to find
that new wants to find the gray area
between the binaries that one can
explore I love thinking about it in
terms of process in terms of all the
variables that come crunching in for
that for that to have and needs meaning
like if the thoughts coming up about
lunch even though I'm trying to do self
care or self inquiry what's the need
there yeah
meaning what is it that is needing to be
taking away if you use internal family
systems language dick shorts as work
that's a protector piece right so that's
like oh I better come in here and make
sure that they don't get too close to
understanding who they really are
because they still need to be sheeple
and just show up in a certain way
because that's all they know and that's
gonna keep them safe so
oh there's thoughts coming up right now
can I just notice the thought thank you
have gratitude for it you're the
protector that was trying to keep me
quote-unquote on track that when I was
five you know I learned or whatever it
is you know get to that later
Hankin right now I just come back to the
path and what is it like to just be here
in the body and notice the thought and
have the awareness of the thought and
maybe at some point get curious about
how did that thought come to be or what
is it trying to protect
we're dosing up towards mindfulness yeah
yeah and the same with addictive
behaviors what's the impulse to have the
drink what's the impulse to go have sex
what's the impulse to go by not that any
of those are bad and Madhuri
yeah but why is why are these impulses
arriving what is the actual process that
has occurred to get to that piece of
content that has happened yeah that's a
great way if the most people can't sit
with themselves if they're not doing
some of those things because they
believe that there's something wrong
with them and it was Annie a lot who
said my mind's like a bad neighborhood I
don't want to go there alone and if you
look at the old Star Wars movies Ronald
remember this I don't know if you will
but there was a place where there was
like a junk field where they was all
crashing in and you know like they I
don't know if you saw the original ones
oh yeah yeah and that's kind of like our
mind it's just like filled with all this
crap and there's this little creature
that pokes its little eyeball out and
you know wants to like drag you under
and you're no Luke Skywalker's like
drowning of course the force of light
that's you know you don't have to do
that open to possibility the sunlight is
you the sunlight you're but you're not a
junkyard yeah well exactly but what I'm
getting at is there's a lot of stuff up
in there so bad to it be grateful be
grateful what it has to teach us don't
say oh it shouldn't be here it's a
junkyard just say there's a lot of
interesting stuff there yeah and to
understand it yeah to aim to understand
the processes better you also said the
the compass of the heart was
super-powerful as well that we're on
this path of I know what is gonna bring
me the most meaning character leveling
up in my life and so I've set my heart
on that path and there's gonna be bad
weather and all the stuff that comes but
the perseverance the good mentorship the
good social fabric that exists around us
to help us get there and help each other
get there so important very quick couple
questions yeah very quick let's power
around through a couple of these what
would you say is a core driving
principle of your life truth
whose truth mine are yours you're
assuming it's a noun hmm seems just more
so when I say truth I mean like the way
what is true right so it's not the known
it's the knowing it's the knowing
quality can we tap into what is it that
is the one who is aware the quality of
knowingness the idea of things being
like the DAO like the way what is the
way can we be curious about what the way
it might be and then fall into it right
that's flow that's truth because that's
the way that's how it goes we're not
imposing ourselves into something we're
dropping into what's already here a lot
easier than friction and fighting and
china cuz we are all you know unique and
snowflakes and i don't mean from the
negative millennial right
no nomenclature I mean we are there's no
other me or other you geneticists aside
playing in China doing whatever they're
doing right there isn't so why are we
here
I mean really what's the truth of that
and can we be curious about it and have
constancy and set the compass toward
being on the path of wanting to know
more what do you think is the truth of
why we're here
well I mean I think it's for everyone to
find out I don't think there's an answer
about one way I think it is a mystery
and I think that's the beauty of it are
we remembering then are we remembering
how we've been I'm not sure about the
question are we remembering then what
our purpose is to be playing here I mean
I think that's implicit in this there's
an assumption that like there's
something to know
mm-hmm and there may not be yeah what if
there was just something to be just
something to be okay
would now I even ask this cook this
follow-up question that would be how
would you redesign civilization boy oh
boy I guess that would just inject it
with more love if possible right just
inject it with important well you use
the word injection before so I think
it's like you know top of mind
dose it with more love well I mean real
love unconditional love has fierce love
and fierce compassion not just what they
would call and some Tibetan Buddhist
circles idiot compassion which is you
know the enabler right you're getting
too much - too many yeah you know means
boundaries
real love is boundaries real love is
boundaries but it's always coming from a
place of connection with oneself and
with the earth and with one another and
so when you have that
there's less of a unmet need that then
creates fear that then kind of
perpetuates that cycle of greed of
insatiability and never having enough
and never being enough and always having
it more and more and more and then that
sets up that other cycle of dominance as
opposed to of connection
I mean research has shown from babies
again and again and again we share we
like to play in the sandbox with one
another kids don't see color we know
rates as a construct who did it benefit
certain ruling classes you know so just
checking all of that that's where
knowledge or education in terms of
history and stuff comes into play yes
learn the history take classes from
white awake org take classes from Leila
Assad you know white supremacy and
me.com take classes from patty DICOM
backslash racism to learn what it means
you can just go google search what the
Scramble for Africa was just you can go
and look at things via Wikipedia through
a lens that's true and we can also look
at the ways in which especially in this
country and in other countries that have
had similar histories the way in which
there was a real benefit an honor and
privilege benefit of certain folks who
even who grew up with perhaps not you
know riches per se right but with a
certain white skin privilege for example
in this country which is something that
most people say well I didn't ask to be
worn in this body right I didn't do
anything wrong or and that's all true
it's not not true that is true
and because of other things like Jim
Crow laws and redlining and the way of
you know incarceration there are other
folks who have brown skin who will never
be able to the way things are currently
constructed
be seen in the same way and have the
same opportunities I mean when Oprah
Winfrey gets stopped in Hermes and she's
a billionaire because people there can't
believe that she could afford a
pocketbook that cost a couple hundred
thousand dollars it's kind of remarkable
the tides are changing and when the
morality is growing the moral arc is
going towards justice as I'm okay said
mm-hmm all right last two wouldn't be
simulation if we didn't ask you what we
in a simulation you know a lot of people
say that right they say that our real
state is our like our sleep state that
this thing you know sort of walking
around doesn't matter that's really my
response how will where are you of where
you are right now as a dog wagging tail
or tail wagging dog that's your
simulation
and the last question is what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world
I don't know that the one for me that's
been so poignant so poignant is healing
so poignant to see that moment of and to
be privileged to experience it witness
and in some way be a part of that that
returned to wholeness I really think
that there's something there that's just
dumb and it comes in many ways it can
come through poetry it can come through
maybe a session that come come through
looking at the ocean or the Grand Canyon
or it can come through making love it
can come through a variety of ways but I
think healing it's probably the most
beautiful thing and my cats know I do
think that it's the first time we had
healing yes they have answered a
beautiful thing in the world yeah
Francesca what a profoundly fascinating
and enlightening episode thank you thank
you
such a pleasure yeah thank you for
having me you're a rock star what a
great time though there's so much waste
oh I'm so grateful for you for Ron for
your work yeah thank you thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we would love to hear from
you in the comments below let us know
some of your thoughts on this episode
also do empower other leaders like
Francesca like simulation support
artists support entrepreneurs support
people that are doing processes of
healing support each other in our
communities give each other that empathy
that deep love and unity and the just
understand the development of
to the world so much so much so much
that check out the links below to
Francesca's work thank you thank you
thank you
and everyone go and build the future go
and manifest your destiny into the world
align that heart compass on that path
and go and build thank you Ron Thank You
Francesca thanks everyone we love you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]